so we've had quite a long flight
ladies and gentlemen a very warm welcome
to geneva the local time here has just
gone 10 minutes past 5.
and then a short drive
and here i am in a hotel room in geneva
and yes we're visiting the large hadron
collider at cern
so have i got everything i need for the
next couple of days filming
let's do the checklist here let's have a
bit of a look
passport check
got my uk europe power adapter
spare tapes i hope i don't need more
than 10
got a socks and toothbrush just in case
my oxford dictionary of physics
but perhaps most important of all i've
got my very own
60 symbols particle physicist yes it's
professor ed copeland
i never leave home without him
and we've been joined by tony tomorrow
as well so we're going to have a full
arsenal and it's quite unusual for you
to get to find out what we're filming
before we do it so here's a chance to
ask some questions tell us what you
might like to see what you might like to
hear the guys talk about when we're at
the large hadron collider just leave
your comments underneath the video in
the usual way but that's it for now from
the hotel room
we're off for dinner bye everyone but
tomorrow we'll be filming and the next
day and hopefully you'll start seeing
the videos next week